6 25 on your wednesday morning we may  not like the orange cones the  construction projects that slow us down  but we should not ignore or disrespect  the men and women who put on the hard  hats those brightly colored vests to get  the work done as part of national work  zone awareness week the folks at the  utah department of transportation found  a neat way to drive home the point that  every person on every work crew has a  family  he comes to all my baseball games  he makes me laugh with this funny jokes  he's the leader of my scout group  she gives me hugs and kisses and keeps  me safe  because the things he does helps all of  us  [Music]  blur our parents are at work  [Music]  and i'm pretty sure that christina  swallow who's the director of the nevada  department of transportation and  everybody at ndot would say here here to  that one buckle up drive carefully  please put down that phone if there is  something driving you crazy email me  traffic 8 8newsnow.com